hey everyone this video will be all
about the creatures and monsters found
in the Star Wars universe which would
include the games movies animations and
comics there are creatures here that can
do off the most versatile ins and even
the planet as a whole
so let's not waste any time and go to
the lists number 20
rancor ran cause were very large
semi-sentient
reptilian carnivores native to the
planet that fermier standing over five
meters tall or almost 17 feet with their
long arms
immense jaws and arm with Heights that
could withstand blaster fire they were
formidable predators
despite this the creatures were
inherently benign and were even
domesticated by the witches of Dathomir
a rat girl named Pat ISA was kept as a
pet by Java the hut in a pit below his
palace curve to which he fed any who
displeased him the Beast was killed by
Luke Skywalker number 19
dhyan yoga die Nagas were very large
omniverse cephalopods that hate from the
planet Valen in a cyclic cluster
although primitive they were actually
sentient and some day enoguh was
sensitive to the force the enoguh was
sentient cephalopods characterized by
seven circuit tentacles and I stopped a
mouse of sharp teeth and several hearts
they could grow up to a length of 7 to
10 meters or 23 to 33 feet their blood
had a blue tint although they could
survive in the open air for short
periods of time that you know go were
entirely dependent on water unless he
completely dried out number 18 Samba
farmers were very large non-sentient
amphibians native to the Gungan swamps
of the planet naboo as well as Onderon
they obtained food by easily knocking
over trees to get at leaves and berries
they also foraged for underwater plants
breathing underwater and swimming with
ease they reach sizes of up to 9 meters
in the wild farmers travel in herds of
up to 12 but sometimes deform breeding
herds of hundreds of family units number
17 blitzes blisters were very rare
half-shell semi aquatic creatures with
tentacles and six sharp legs around 14
to 15 meters of 50 feet in length they
shared some common ancestry with the
Sarlacc Rathore and Vic
they could notably be found on scare
off' where they dragged insufficiently
vigilant passes by into lagoons to eat
them during the Clone Wars slaver das
dinar owned ablixa switch he kept above
his ship at the tecora when dinar was
forced escape from Kairos about the
tecora he unleashes perplexes upon Jedi
Knight Anakin Skywalker number 16 OPC
killers the OPC killer sometimes
referred to simply as an Opie was a very
large meat-eating crustaceous secret of
approximately 20 metres or 66 feet in
length a hybrid of crustacean and fish
that inhabited the watery planet core of
Naboo it was the third largest predator
on Naboo only smaller than the Kolo claw
fish and the even largest sand Sando
aqua monster which bought pray on it
another predatory enemy of it is the
titanium number 15 Goro the Guru was a
gargantuan beasts used in the darkest a
arena on Cato Neimoidia the immense
bipedal creature possessed a hunch
stands two human-like hands with
opposable thumbs two hearts and four
security cameras equipped with rog
Security's artificial intelligence the
garokk was a creature of immense size of
more than 20 meters or 70 feet and
powerful strength and could easily crush
a rancor with one hand
it had a large muscular midsection and
forearms whence of arm and upper leg
were more skeletal number-14 by lava
taranta the Palazzo transer was one of
several species of transit that lived
and were native to the planet Alderaan
which was destroyed by the Galactic
Empire and thus became extinct they were
considered the second largest of the
Tranter species
smaller only to the great Tranter unlike
the other species the pilot of transit
possessed black skin on his dorsal side
while it had white skin on his underside
their noses were short and pointed their
size could be anywhere between 20 to 30
meters or 65 to a hundred feet long
number 13 the Colo claw fish the code of
claw fish was a large nightmarish
creature found in the depths of the
Naboo seas as well as the Kodak C&C
Nicolo had a flat he liked body a
bioluminescent tail a crocodile like
head row of sharp teeth and a set of
mandibles they had a set of venomous
fangs that could use just on their prey
these masters were over 40 meters or 130
feet in length number 12 the tight even
the tight even up Goths were huge flying
reptilians that perch on mountains and
crags and the remote edges of oceans and
swamps of Naboo it was assumed that the
Gulf's or the Titian's eat carrion since
large animal bones and limbs were found
near their purchase they also have been
observed feeding on the dead floating
carcasses of Santo Aqua monsters their
wingspan measures more than a hundred
meters or 330 feet across number 11 the
syllabus the syllabus was a gargantuan
serpent-like creature with a lengthy
whip-like tail at 97 metres long the
Zillo beast towered over all species on
its native planet of my last array and
was considered at the top of its food
chain until it was presumed extinct its
tail between eight sharp spikes and the
Beast itself uniquely possess a third
arm protruding from its back its heavy
plated Armour was invovled to explosions
blaster fire and even lightsaber strikes
number 10 the greater krayt dragon the
greater krayt dragon was a largest
subspecies of the great dragon a
predatory reptile from Tatooine it would
submerge itself in the shifting sands
using his strong limbs to swim through
the dunes the greater create dragon
first appeared a weight as a skeleton in
a Tatooine desert in Star Wars Episode
four a new hope the skeleton used to
portray the greater krayt dragon
consists a fiberglass replica sauropod
bones
this creature measures more than a
hundred meters in length
number nine the Sarlacc the solids were
dangerous carnivorous creatures as well
as one of Jabba the Hutt's favorites
pets that inhabited the great pit of
Carkoon in the June sea of Tatooine
solids began their lives as posed and
were able to travel great distances when
a male and a female encountered one
another the smaller male would
parasitically fate of the female
diminishing her size while increasing
his own
they are around 100 meters in length on
average numerate Sando aqua monster the
sound of aqua monsters were enormous
muscular predators that could be found
in the oceans and lakes of Naboo
although they could grow up to 200
meters they were rarely seen thanks to
the sharp teeth they were capable of
biting through the strong armor of the
OPC killers measuring between 160 and
200 meters or 650 feet in length and
over 54,000 tons the Santo aqua monster
out there named to the gigantic size
number seven the great Tranter the great
hunter was the largest of the transit
species native to the planet Alderaan
and became extinct when the world was
destroyed its size was estimated at
being 15 times longer than the pylorus
rancher that could put it anywhere
between 300 and 450 meters long or a
thousand to 1500 feet as was expected
the wings of the beasts possess strong
muscles that allow them to fly in the
skies of their home world number six
fergal ultra per girl was a species of
massive whale like creatures a live in
the deep space traveling from star
system to star system it was their
natural ability to fly through the
hyperspace that inspired sentience to
develop the hyperdrive technology the
per girl ultra was a large per girl who
led a group of per girls his length
estimated around half the length of an
embarrassed Star Destroyer putting it at
between 700 and 800 metres long number
five space lock hexagons also known as
space lots of giant space locks where
members of a silicon-based species that
resided in the hollows of asteroids at
least one such creature lived in the
Hots asteroid belt space lock reached
full maturity at 10 meters and
reproduced by splitting into two smaller
separate bodies but if a space law was
incapable of this process its growth
continued uninterrupted potentially
reaching lengths of up to 900 metres
long number fold the Colossus was the
Colossus was was space faring insects
that grew to be over a kilometer in
length their varied diet consisted of
living matter such as space lots
inanimate matter like asteroids minerals
and even pure energy such as stellar
radiation
Colossus was were one of a number of
titanic creatures that live and native
to the planet of eatle in a stainless
note
when they died the local miners
refurbished the carapace to create a to
lien or haulers number three the near a
manta near a mantis will type of flying
creature found throughout the galaxy
dwelling on planets like Tatooine the
Rishi moon and even on the void of space
in the kaledin Nebula baby knee brace
could be found on the Ragusa and in
space these gigantic creatures were the
size of space capital ships with a
wingspan alone longer than an imperial
star destroyer at 1674 metres or more
than a mile
number two the suma Voronov the simmer
vermin odds were gargantuan spacefaring
beasts with tentacles and multiple eyes
they dwelt in the Akitas maelstrom and
were embedded in legends of what Travis
may encounter in the year 10 before the
Battle of Yavin han Solo and the press
of Beckett's gang unintentionally awoke
Asuma verminous near a more cluster in
the movie we could see that the Kessel
run monster or the suma berminat was in
the range of five to ten kilometers or
three to six miles across is stretched
from technical to tentacle number one
still sail the most mysterious and yet
the biggest of all the creatures in the
Star Wars universe
these creatures are made of some sort of
organic cosmic membranes that cannot be
detected by the naked eye and yes they
do grow estimates put them around
thousands of kilometers wide while one
of the YouTube channels that we really
like eggheads Lara tells us that if
uninterrupted these still sails would be
around a hundred thousand kilometers so
this brings us to the end of the list
and do you like share and subscribe for
more related content on monsters guide
you and not small and if you don't see
us on your YouTube feed then you should
probably click on a notification bell
for regular and actual notifications